[Music]
well it's a great honor and the men's
pleasure for me to give this talk today
at Ellen s 46 and thus to be able to
recall those marvelous four years that I
have spent at the Center for Theoretical
Physics between 68 and 72 I must say
that both my wife and I still remember
those years at some of the very best
perhaps the very best of our life and of
course we can say that that was youth or
the best of our first child here the
discovery of a such a great country but
it's also the fact that we came back to
Europe and to Israel with a feeling of
having reached ourselves and to have
made so many nice friends whom I really
thank very much today in fact I would
like to conclude this by thanking most
of all the person who sort of twisted my
arm and brought me here and with whom I
had a beautiful collaboration this is
Sergio Fubini who will arrive today to
join us in the celebration so I
the subject of of my talk the subject of
my talk is from dual models to strings
and okay that subject will be covered in
this first five points and then I hope
to have some time to tell you about how
things have developed since that period
I arrived at MIT in this in the
beginning of September 68 but a few
months earlier in the summer of 68 I had
worked at what became called known as
the Dewar resonance model and I want to
start my story from there now I get
often upset when reading accounts of
early days of string theory you hear
Veneziano has just opened Bateman and
found the beta function sitting there
and that was the start of string theory
now I think this is an important lesson
this was a rather long lived model as
you will see it died and resurrected
again and I guess they the reason for
that is that it was some good blending
of phenomenology and of theory so let me
go over the main phenomenological inputs
of the dual resonance model and then the
theoretical ones those days people
working on atomic interactions knew that
the spectrum of a tronic state was
extremely rich many many resonances were
discovered almost daily or weekly now
those resonances were found to lie on
almost straight right trajectory when we
we'll say more in a moment and then
another property that darlin horn and
Schmidt found is that the resonance
description of a strong interaction
collision was complimentary you say dual
duality to another description given in
terms of the cross channel exchange of
red poles
finally the quantum numbers of the
resonances which were being discovered
we're all consistently non exalted by
this meaning that their quantum numbers
could be described in terms of QQ bar or
three quark systems now to those
phenomenological inputs we try to add
some good theory Oh
one was to impose causality in terms of
good analytic properties of scattering
amplitude the second property was exact
crossing symmetry and finally we took
they the perhaps bold idea to work in a
narrow resonance approximation an
approximation in which resonances have
zero width don't decay and therefore the
scattering amplitude instead of being
described in terms of bright Wigner is
described in terms of simple poles so
that was the beginning of the dual
resonance model and as I arrived at MIT
surger pavilion died started immediately
to look into more properties of those
models and the first thing to do for us
was clear it was to count the states in
other words what was what physics was
lying behind those poles in the
scattering amplitude of these models and
well first of all we knew that the poles
or this were equally spaced in the
square mass in other words the mass of
the resonances were given by this very
simple formula where capital n is an
integer and alpha Prime and alpha zero
were two constants to be fitted to the
data or pictorially to plot them on the
angular momentum and square mask on your
stage and they were all line on straight
line vegetation trees but still the
question was how many states were there
at level in and the answer to this
question could be answered in principle
easily in practice was a different story
by using a fundamental property of
resonances known as factorization by
looking at the amplitude for any initial
channel to produce any final channel
near the pole we could try to write it
in terms of the product of the coupling
of the initial state to some resonance
times the coupling of the same resonance
to the final state times the resonance
propagator which was just a tall and if
you could succeed to represent indeed
for every initial and final state that
amplitude in terms of a finite sum of
factorizable contributions like that
then the number of terms that that
sample tane was nothing but they leveled
the generous now of course knowing that
the resonances had higher and higher
angular momentum gave us already some
hint that there had to be degeneracy for
instance the most naive expectation
would be that the generous would be 2 n
plus 1 2 J plus 1 or probably higher
because we knew there were also states
of lowers being lying down but the
answer we go by the explicit check
zatia was absolutely surprising so what
we and bide action mandus them God was
that the degeneracy was drawing enormous
ly like in exponential of the square
root of n therefore recalling this
formula as an exponential of the mass at
large M okay that made quite a bit of
sense
in fact it agreed with some model put
forward by Hagedorn much earlier to
explain some spectra of secondary tiles
in atomic collision of course this
maximal temperature later on was
reinterpreted in QCD as the phase
transition to the quark-gluon plasma but
that's much later and that formula was
also that exponential spectrum and the
concept of the maximum temperature was
also applied by kirsten wank and Steve
Weinberg in those days to the early
universe now so the first discovery was
this extreme richness of the spectrum of
the dual resonance model and what came
next was that this very rich spectrum
could me could be represented in a very
simple way which goes as follows is
quite simple you take a vacuum call
it zero and you act on it with our
monocle see later type creation
operators so you introduce the usual a a
daggers of your monocle see laters
except you introduce them in several
species each harmonic oscillator has a
Lorentz index mu going from zero one and
three and another integer n which just
takes over the natural numbers and you
impose some sort of standard commutation
relations to in creation and destruction
operators with with a little catch
that you have to put a funny minus sign
when the commutator concern a timelike
component and that was simply by Lorentz
invariance then a generic state which
could achieve that factorization was
simply the general state that you could
get by applying repeatedly creation
operators on the back so they were
labeled by just occupation numbers the
usual thing and the mass formula for
such a state was given by this operator
the mass square operator was just the
occupation number except that they were
weighted by this integer n that explains
immediately the huge degeneracy as
coming from the fact that you have
infinitely many oscillators and M goes
to infinity and that the frequencies of
the oscillators are all multiple of a
fundamental frequency that's this
sitting there now that already smells of
a string we know that the string has
many vibration modes and there multiple
of the fundamental frequency and holger
nilsson Laney Susskind and many others
said aha but that must be history but
that was not coming yet
let me rather go back to this problem
with relativistic in various the
relativistic invariance of the theory
implied as I said that the time out
light of C laters a dagger 0 m we're
giving states of negative norm when
acting on the vacuum because of this
minus sign in the commutator this this
negative knowledge state violated the
probability conservation and we called
them the ghosts ok they were bad States
which could view in completely the
theory
then what I could call ghost hunting
started and what does that mean well it
means that fortunately the full set of
states that I presented in the previous
transparency was redundant it was
sufficient to give factorization but not
necessary why because some linear
combinations of those states were
decoupled from any I and any earth call
them thus poorer States states which
really be coupled and which you can
dispose off then the real question was
does one have a positive norm Hilbert
space after the removal of the spurious
states and not before
and in fact some ghosts those associated
in fact with the first awesome the time
light component of the first oscillator
where indeed found to be spurious by
surger myself but that was hardly enough
because we had an infinity of such time
like creation operators which were all
producing negative norm states at that
point vida solo made a very important
discovery
he found that for a very special value
of alpha not one of those two parameters
in the mass formula in fact for the
value alpha not equal one the number of
spirit states increase dramatically in
fact to put it in formula simply while
search and I found that a certain
operator which now is called L minus 1
acting on any state and which contained
the first harmonic oscillator gave
spurious States virasoro noticed that
for alpha 0 equal 1 any el- in an
infinite set of such operators acting on
any state was producing spurious states
so this was a very important
generalization which opened the way to
the possibility not the proof but the
possibility that
ghost could be completely eliminated
thus making the theory well-defined and
consistent well to prove the no ghost no
ghost theorem took a little while and it
was very important at this point to
develop a formalism which would be as
efficient as elegant as compact as
possible and this is the period I would
like to call algebras vertices and
fields it started actually with a work
by Yahtzee which is not often recalled
69 you notice that if you take that
operator L minus 1 that created pure
States the mass operator agreed defined
as L 0 and the third operator which also
has some meaning
never mind L plus 1 these three
operators satisfy the lie algebra of so2
1 which is a non compact version of
ordinary 3-dimensional rotations in fact
I mean if you since at this time you may
be a bit sleepy I certainly a.m. you may
think that this is the algebra of
angular momentum but of course this sign
is wrong and this sign is also wrong ok
you try to compare with the algebra of
angular momentum
so Yahtzee found this so2 1 algebra
underlying those operators and then we
searched in a paper we published in a
special volume of analog so physics
dedicated to the late I'm especially to
my head by the way the great pleasure of
meeting at a white pen Institute before
coming here we decided to try to take
the full set of virasoro operators
ailment
and l0 again and then some new operators
L plus M and try to generalize this
result and then we obtained obtained
should be caught on both the algebra I
mean are still reading that later and
eating my biting my fingers we propose
that that was the correct generalization
of that algebra to the virasoro case
okay
in fact before the paper appeared in
print they late Joe wise then I think
that Berkley pointed out that we have
made a stupid mistake and that this
algebra had an extra C number sitting on
the right hand side a kind of swinger
term and that the correct algebra was
this term plus a certain C over 12 and
humans and times the Chronicle Delta and
and minus m and Betsy turned out to be D
or the number of space-time dimensions
in which we could consider this here
okay so you see the crucial difference
and I mean I think a posteriori this
teaches me an important lesson I mean we
we couldn't guess anything else than
this
this of course reproduces yahtzee's
algebra correctly if N and M are 0 1 1
or minus 1 but the stupid thing is that
we could have done the explicit check
and we tested so much our intuition not
to do it and this was obviously a big
mistake anyway this is in fact the
famous algebra of the bursar operators
usually refer to as virasoro algebra but
i want to point out that it was
discovered
well half at MIT and half at birth
now the next thing was the following in
the work of Nambu and Fubini garden and
myself sorry I didn't mention the names
earlier this is the work where the
operators were introduced the scattering
amplitudes of the dual model were
expected we're well written as
expectation values of product of birth
disease and propagators in analogy with
field theory all constructed out of
these are Monaco C Labor's but we know
in field theory their monetary letters
come as the Fourier coefficients of this
function of a field Phi of X now as it
has consistently happened in string
theory and the dual model you had to
work backward we had the operators but
we didn't have the fields the field so
we had to work backwards but that was
not too hard and we with Sergio Fubini
we introduced a an analogous field which
whose Fourier coefficients were
precisely the harmonic oscillators that
have been used well that field had this
funny appearance now we didn't call it X
mu we call it Q but in any case it had
to do with some position now sometimes
position is called X sometimes it's
called Q in fact the first piece is like
a position operator of a normal particle
this P mu is nothing but the momentum
operator of a normal particle and this
is the new piece but we did not know
what that new piece meant anyway we had
this field now out of this field one can
construct with so called vertex
operators and in terms of the vertex
operators finally they
the scattering amplitude could be
written simply as application value of a
product of these operators precisely
like in lsz formalism you write the
scattering amplitude for n particles you
related to the expectation value of a
product of local fields so this
formalism led to the possibility of
studying further the the theory and to
its extensions which I mentioned here in
particular de Vaca del Giudice Fubini
used it to construct physical states
through which finally a proof of the
no-goes theorem came about by Richard
Brower
and independently by Goddard and thorne
they proved that they were indeed no
negative norm states in the theory
provided the number D of space-time
dimensions was less or equal than 26 let
me jump here in another development
loops namely corrections to this narrow
resonance approximation to give
resonances a width were constructed and
Lovelace was the first one to point out
that actually the theory had to be
indeed equal 26 so the number of
space-time dimensions in which this
objects lived had to be quantized if you
want and then the other extension which
is very important is the one by never
Schwarz Vermont they constructed a do a
resonance model with both fermions and
bosons and you may know not know that
that's where
supersymmetry was first found at least
in the West before it was applied to
feel fear okay now once once you have a
field as I told you so we went from the
creation and destruction operators onto
a field once you have the field you can
ask what is the field theory underlying
the dual resonance model now a
posteriori they am the answer is simple
but of course it took the genius of
Nambu and also Gatto to guess the right
field theory and the right field theory
was the one of a relativistic string in
fact inspired by the relativistic point
these people wrote in action for a
massless relativistic string in a very
simple form the number go to action
classical action for a string is nothing
but I'm sorry this is a bit messed up
this doesn't belong to the formula minus
T times the integral over the area
element or if you want times the total
area swept by the string which is this
line as it sweeps a surface during its
motion so you have to imagine this sheet
in embedded in the capital D dimensional
space-time here represented by x1 x2 x3
but many more and the the action of
number and God was simply proportional
to the area spanned by sweat by the
string in more mathematical form that
area is related to the X mu that I was
talking about by this formula where
alpha and beta
can take values 1 & 2 & simply label the
coordinates on this two-dimensional
surface never mind about the detail now
this turned out to be a system with
constraints namely this D coordinates X
knew of the string are not really old
physical in the sense that only the
motion orthogonal to the string did is
physical you see a motion of the string
which leads this surface and change in
motion in the in the plane in the
surface has no effect and so its
unphysical
for sure this is what eliminates some of
the bad degrees of freedom which were
giving us the problem and in fact the
algebra of the classical constraints of
the system was nothing but the algebra
of the bureau operator that Fubini and i
had the one without see numbers you see
again this moving backward okay
we had a quantum theory and now through
this work one is trying to reconstruct
the classical theory of which what we
had in our hands was the quantum version
and that is very interesting because
classically the angular momentum and the
mass of such a system is continuous of
course and it turns out to satisfy
simple relation the angular momentum of
any string has to be bound by alpha
prime times m square where alpha prime
just our old friend Rachel slope is
related to this parameter T of the
action by this inverse relationship now
however things change drastically at the
quantum level
at the quantum level
J of course is quantized as everybody
knows and so is this mask way less
evident but it is a fact now in fact you
can impose now the validity of the
constraints not only the kind of the
classic console stated over to the
quantum level and that was the
fundamental work of God are called stone
red Caribbean thorn 73 who found this
way to light from quantization that now
at the quantum level they correct
results where the angular momentum is
less than not a prime M square plus
alpha 0 H bar now I put back h bar which
was one in most of the previous formula
and then of course they found also that
the algebra reserve operators had this
extra central charge from the string
point of view and the consistency name
imposing the constraint of the quantum
level required both alpha 0 equal 1 and
the central charge to be 26 therefore
required the equal 26 and this was from
the stream point of view but in perfect
agreement with a real server condition
alpha 0 equal 1 the Lovelace result
about loops with a no ghost theorem ok
and well let me skip this for a second
with this work we can say that the dual
string theory had reached full maturity
ok the circle was closed but I also want
to point out this very interesting
conclusion which as you will see is good
and bad at the same time and this is
that states with zero mass and non zero
angular momentum which are excluded for
classical string because of that
inequality J less than M Squared are
allowed even necessary at the quantum
level ok this is a very important point
which we'll see
means the death of the old stream and
means life for the new one if I what do
I mean by this that you see the string
had reached complete maturity was a
perfectly elegant theory but of course
as it should be the case nature had its
last work has has to have the last word
on whether a theory is good or bad and
unfortunately there were three basic
properties of this beautiful consistent
theory which represented as many death
sentences for the old Hadron extreme one
at the massless state as I say at the
quantum level you get this master state
spinning master state and we know if
there is one feature of strong
interactions we know for sure is this
strong range nature the excessive number
of space-time dimensions we were forced
into that again by quantization and it
was an obvious problem and third less
evident is the momentum cut off that
there was at a GV scale
now this last third property looked
phenomenologically good at first
in fact hagedorn model was based
precisely on the idea that there was a
cut-off an exponential cutoff on hi
Petey but at least these three sets of
experiments the slack experiments on
deep inelastic collisions on which we
will hear tomorrow the CEA experiment a
plus C minus two hurdles showing a
remarkably constant R finally the icer
is our experiments at CERN on large
angle had an Hadron Collider like speaky
hadn't had an collisions they all
revealed the presence of point light
constituents within the hydrants and
they were none in the stream so this
Third Point was really pretty big and
now at that time to CD came about with
quarks gluons with asymptotic freedom
which could justify the naive partner
model could represent the data and so on
in a dual string approach though
beautiful consistent
whatever you like had to concede defeat
sorry I had to erase this I was saying
serum and jockey stock for the other
side of the coin but he talked about
strings also instead switches subject
now well the reason probably why I'm
here is that this was really not the
whole end of the story for Strings so I
want to come to strings of the 90s and
so this means a jump of twenty years and
I will go quickly through those twenty
years but just by mentioning one point
that the bold proposal of shark and
short in 1974 as I said strings at the
quantum level have inevitably massless
spinning states now such states do
appear in nature though not as hadrons
so their idea was why not use strings
for something else
electromagnetic interactions weak
interactions gravity because other
varieties of strings have massless
particle of spin to for instance and
also why not for strong interactions but
at the quark-gluon rather than at a
higher level so well that proposal went
quite unnoticed for some time meanwhile
the standard model got really
established on firmer and firmer
experimental grounds as we know but okay
something which is often forgetting
forgot it failed in one respect could
not incorporate gravity okay it's not
yet a theory of quantum gravity on the
other hand as John Schwarz puts it
quantifies really clashes with gravity
and string theory can't even exist
without it and furthermore seems to be a
consistent theory of quantum gravity
also of course there was the famous
breakthrough of Keenan Schwartz in
1984 and all this Plus this frustration
about standard quantum field theories
being unable to cope with quantum
gravity brought back strings in the
front line so in my last five minutes I
want to give you a little taste of how
string theory has changed has made its
goals extremely bigger but okay we'll
see that
don't be an easy job to check that in
fact the 1990 version of the string
action is slightly different from the
one of Nambu and gato although one can
prove some limits the equivalence of the
two it looks more like general
relativity in two dimensions and in fact
following the work of several groups the
new action which is usually called the
Polyakov action due to many to work with
many groups contains our old friend X of
Z but also a new friend a new a new
person a two dimensional matrix that's
why I call it general relativity in two
dimension these are for instance is just
the Riemann curvature or the scalar
curvature associated with this mech and
okay these are the fields to be
quantized you'll see it's really a
revolutionary point of view namely you
have to think of the position operator
of the string and the two-dimensional
metric as the quantum field to be
quantized or integrated over if you like
more Simon
by contrast the fields which I
underlined here Jim you knew I use this
capital Jimmy knew because it's
convention Phi and others are functions
of X this is not indicated and I really
like the ordinary space-time field that
quantum field theory usually deals with
which quantum field theory by definition
quantizes okay now and then plans into
problems when dealing with gravity
trainers now the good news of this
construction most of this is checked and
true I mean maybe there is some slight
wishful thinking - the good news is that
the conditions of quantum consistency
namely the correct algebra of
constraints remember that those which
gave us alphas u equal one and V equal
twenty six leads actually two equations
of motions for the space-time fields
which are the usual classical field
theory equations plus short distance
correction what does it mean and
instance equation for the gravitational
field or the yang-mills equation of the
Maxwell equation they come from the
quantum consistency of of that strained
action okay of that two dimensional
general relativity it's very interesting
classical field theory follows from the
first quantization of this thing not
from classical string now what about
second quantization said I mean the
reason why we quantize usually the
electromagnetic field and which I also
to quantize and successfully the
gravitational field is because we want
to have second quantization effect now
the remarkable thing about string theory
is that there doesn't seem to be any
need and if that is probably wrong to
quantize G and Phi the usual quantum
field theory way like imposing local
commutation relations in fact the
typical second quantization effects like
pair creation running of coupling
constant what you have you follow simply
from first quantization of the string
namely same first quantization which
gives the classical equations if you
carry that further by being careful
about how you integrate over the two
dimensional metal I cannot explain the
details
reproduces also the second quantization
effects it's very nice you have a field
theory in the dimensions any D in
principle maybe some limitation and you
can do all of that by 21 ties in a two
dimensional theory now the usual
ultraviolet divergences are tamed both
in the gauge and in the gravity sector
this actually follows from the finite
string size that strings are acquired
from quantization strings are like I've
Monique oscillators and you certainly
remember the Delta X where their monocle
see later goes like the square root of H
bar of course times the string tension
you get a fundamental length okay this
was the cutoff which gave us trouble for
a drama string vis a vie of you know
experiments but certainly the cutoff is
there and now it's welcome
instead of being well it's welcome
because infinities in quantum field
theory mean inconsistency if the fear is
not normalizable or some lack of
productivity for instance we normalized
parameters are arbitrary finiteness
means productivity and in fact drinks
can be shown to have really no free
adjustable parameters the parameters
that enter in the theory are those which
follow from the vacuum the generous okay
now in fact there are two vacuum
parameters means to in theory which have
dimensions of a speed in the length and
they are respectively the speed of light
and these fundamental lengths which
turns out to be the planck constant of
the theory there is this very
interesting relationship in string
theory between the planck constant and
the Kitab which are completely unrelated
in filthy
furthermore that feel phi which is
called the dilettante controls the
fine-structure constant and the Newton
constant and therefore the to get
related and since they have different
dimensions they're related also to the
fundamental length and other scalar
fields determining principle the fate of
extra dimensions and so that what is the
gap scale and what is the symmetry there
sorry I'm very sketchy about this point
just to give you a flavor of how much is
at stake now there are some bad news and
these are related to what Herman was
saying if you which cannot be wrong
cannot be right I think you said that
right and this is this problem that the
relation between the gauge couplings and
the Newton constant tell us that the new
strings are not larger than say 10 times
the Planck length so there will be 10 to
the minus 32 centimeters 8 and then for
most purposes they look like points and
therefore how can we shoot them down how
can we really see a distinction between
strings and points you see the old
atronics strings were ten to the minus
thirteen centimeters big so they were
giving effects at the GeV scale and they
could be ruled out simply on
experimental grounds and now I think
this is a bit related to what to what
Alan Guth was saying when you talk about
these scales when you talk about these
energies probably there is only one hope
and this is cosmology or using the
universe as a whole as a way to test and
here is something a little bit in the
same spirit you see the theory has
massless scalars what mean what I mean
by a hope I mean a hope to be able to
shoot down the string okay or maybe
prove that it's correct
now these are coupled to matter with
typical gravitational strength
it's like a bronze dicker scaler but
with a small Omega parameter you know
what I mean their effect could
contradict the basic tests of general
relativity
maybe they explain why Vicky's vice cops
feels heavier and heavier but I'm sure
now they are massless because of the
flat direction you see which implied in
arbitrariness in the vacuum expectation
values and therefore in the fundamental
constants of nature I told you there are
no fundamental constants the only one
time because the vacuum appears to be
still me degenerate in perturbation
theory so there is a non determinacy on
the value of some fundamental parameters
at the same time as you know from the
Goldstone's theorem there are massless
particles which travel in this plant
direction this master particle give
trouble so ultimately also this vacuum
degeneracy is related to some symmetry
which start to understand so it seems to
me that the conclusion is that the new
strings are also probably doomed unless
some mechanism is found to break this
huge symmetry which keeps the vacuum
degenerate and therefore keeps this
unwanted scalars massless and therefore
also limits the productivity of them of
the field so perhaps fortunately the new
string gain may turn out to be in all
wing or all those game and I think that
is how physics should be and especially
in the case of such a pretentious theory
you